row before winning three in a row so he
has form
um i think someone just needs to talk to
him and just say okay you've still got a
chance man
just um keep fighting you are capable
you are strong enough he played a great
game actually for three quarters of that
one
but he did come under some uh genius
attack by mama durov at the end
and uh yeah mom joe jumping up to third
place now
actually it's it's is that sort of a
surprise him being all the way up there
um not necessarily to me i i've seen him
play so well in rapid and blitz before
but
he's a bit inconsistent sometimes it
just seems that he's bang on form
uh in this event and great news for
mamajara fans because he likes to keep
his fans entertained
all right sorry i'm sitting here is he
looking over this game and should he be
looking over this game or should he now
you know it's 20 minutes until the next
one super important for him
should he just forget this i mean
ideally this is all down to
a personal matter of taste and what is
going to work for you
to suddenly get your motivation and just
to be present focused